Andre is with us in Grand Rapids
Michigan hey Andre how are you hey I'm
doing well thank you for taking the call
sure what's up so I'm currently
finishing up my last year of school and
I'll graduate in April with about
$23,000 in debt the good thing for me is
that I have a job lined up I've already
accepted it starting in around September
and it pays really well and it also has
a signing bonus and the thing that I'm
considering is doing a Europe trip maybe
two to three three to four thousand
dollars a few weeks in Europe just kind
of as a graduation gift to myself mm-hmm
okay we already gave yourself a gift
twenty-three thousand of student loans
what's your degree in I'm a double major
in International Business and management
information systems and then I'll have a
minor in German good for you well done
and so what's your new job I'll be a
technology consultant and I'll be doing
a lot of traveling and just really
helping businesses solve their
technology problems how much your travel
will be in Europe it depends on which
client I'm working with and what project
I'm on okay so there's no guarantees the
majority of projects will be in the US
and how much they know how much you're
making
I'll make 80 thousand a year Wow
straight out of school
yep and my final bonus will be twelve
thousand five hundred that is absolutely
awesome congratulations sir yeah very
very well done well none of these
decisions are going to bankrupt you okay
the the biggest problem you get into is
muscle memory any time you're learning
something and you do it right it locks
in to your brain and when you do it
wrong it locks in to your brain and so
the people who for instance are
professional athletes they don't just
practice a lot they practice doing it
right a lot does that make sense yeah
and the problem with your idea
is not that it's probably going to ruin
your life or something like that it's
not it's not that it's so crazy that I
can't breathe when I'm talking to you or
something like that it's not it's just
really bad muscle memory you're 23
thousand dollars in debt and you're
gonna and you're taking $12,000 and
you're going to Europe that's just bad
muscle memory it's a bad it's a bad way
to start out your adult life as being a
kid for 90 more days so I wonder if
there's I just wonder if there's another
way to get at the same problem and yet
do it in a way that that sounds wiser
because the reason you even asked me the
question and you kind of knew I'd
probably go there right right I mean so
the reason you even asked me the
question is it's tickling you inside of
your conscience you're kind of going I
don't know it sounds like really like a
lot of fun I mean I got an international
business degree I can speak German this
is gonna be a blast you know I got the
money in my hand with a signing bonus
and on the other hand it kind of feels
dumb and that's what was going on inside
your brain wasn't it well for me it was
that stop was that going on inside your
brain or not okay that's what I mean
that's what I'm saying you were doing
which just means you're intelligent
that's all I mean so you did took it's
why you asked me the question so let's
think about this is there another way to
do this how much vacation do you get
with this company in your 100 crew the
days every pay period and then it'll
come to around 25 days vacation a year
so what is so wrong with going next
summer the summer after after you've
worked a year and take 25 days in Europe
and paid cash for it you'll be
definitely you'll be debt-free you'll be
making 80 grand a year you save up the
money you're gonna have a blast I think
the biggest thing for me now that I
think of it is that I miss some of the
people that I met while I was abroad
when I'm studying there and they want me
there you see them yeah you're right
Willie I'll go right oh they live there
okay yeah I mean it's it's just it just
feels more I mean how
horn am I about you doing that zero cuz
your stud I mean you're coming out of
school making 80 grand who does that I
mean come on me that's killer
that's awesome and you got a twelve
thousand dollar signing bonus to boot
you know so I am not worried about your
life turning out alright you know you're
gonna be alright so you can do either
one and you'll survive you're gonna be
okay
I just always forced myself if I'm torn
like that
why is it I'm torn and is there a way to
do it that feels more grown-up
it feels wiser and hey you and I are
gonna be friends no matter what you do
so I appreciate you calling and talking
to me about it I'm honored that I was
included in your conversation of being
torn but if I woke up in your shoes I
don't think you're gonna lose hardly
anything waiting a year to take the trip
you get twenty five days that's a
three-week trip in Europe that ain't no
slouch for twenty four years old
paying cash to make an 80 grand that
ain't no slouch I didn't even see the
ocean till I was 12 so you know I mean
come on
you're gonna be okay III yeah you're
gonna be okay either way you're
obviously a rock star so and I think
that's part of why you were torn is you
you have this sense about you you have
some common sense to go with your
economics and your German and so forth
so good good call it's good to talk to
you sir either way I hope you enjoy your
trip